what are the mechanics of shooting a
scene where your character has his eyes
gouged out of his skull you know that's
happened to you on two separate
occasions of course the unforgettable
death in Game of Thrones but then that
final scene of equalizer too he puts his
thumbs into my eyes and they've got
piping uh tubing
through his uh body into his forearms
forearms to his thumbs and just like
pumping this like cool blood so gentle
like the gentlest guy ever felt no
pressure at all fleshy bits that they
were kind of placing all over my face
and pumping blood so that it would pool
you know and spread through the
amphitheater for this like good wide and
that sort of shot of the two of us from
above dead asleep because it was like it
was so hot and this stuff was so cooling
I realized now that I need to be laid
out with pieces of Flesh and uh pulling
blood and maybe I'll finally get a good
[__] night's sleep